welcome to gk essentials where we
explore basics and useful tips for
getting up and running with gke i'm
caslin fields a developer advocate here
at google cloud where i focus on google
kubernetes engine as well as open source
kubernetes
[Music]
kubernetes is designed to enable and
manage apps at scale but with great
scale comes great potential for wasted
resources
even small inefficiencies can add up and
make clusters more unwieldy than they
need to be in this episode we'll talk
about what it means to optimize a gke
cluster to run your apps as efficiently
as possible
[Music]
first what does it mean to run a cluster
optimally ideally your true goal should
be to run your applications as
efficiently as possible
you want to make sure that your apps
have all the resources they need with as
few extra resources provisioned as
possible
a problem with any system of sufficient
scale is that it's hard to tell if
you're using your resources efficiently
in this video we'll take a quick look at
tools and capabilities to help you
optimize the efficiency of your gke
clusters by understanding and managing
your resources as effectively as
possible
[Music]
generally the more time and effort you
have to spend on cluster optimization
tasks the less time you have to focus on
the applications and other tasks that
are core to your business or what you're
really trying to accomplish with your
kubernetes cluster
auto scaling provides a way for you to
set up your clusters to optimize
themselves automatically
in gke there are four dimensions of auto
scaling you should think about
the cluster auto scaler can increase or
decrease the number of virtual machines
in your cluster according to demand
the node auto provisioner can
automatically pick the right size of
virtual machines for your workloads
the horizontal pod autoscaler or hpa can
increase or decrease the number of pods
running your workload according to
demand
and the vertical pod autoscaler or vpa
can help you understand the resources
your workload actually needs so you can
set resource requests and limits
appropriately
[Music]
if you haven't check out our video
introduction to gk auto scaling for more
about the four dimensions of auto
scaling in gke
[Music]
gke autopilot mode takes this idea of
reducing the time and effort you have to
spend on cluster optimization to the
next level
gk autopilot mode is our most fully
managed version of google kubernetes
engine and both the worker nodes and
kubernetes control plane are managed for
you by google you just tell your gk
autopilot mode cluster what workload you
want to run with its resource requests
and limits set of course and gke
autopilot mode sorts out the underlying
infrastructure for you
no need to configure cluster auto
scaling or node auto provisioning
no need to worry about bin packing those
virtual machines you pay only for the
resources your workloads actually use
if you haven't check out our video
introduction to gk cluster modes to
learn more about how gk autopilot mode
compares with gk standard mode so
basically gk autopilot mode is doing the
infrastructure parts of auto scaling for
you but you'll still need to worry about
the workload scaling parts the
horizontal and vertical pod auto scalers
luckily gke has a tool to make that
easier too
a newer addition to gke's portfolio of
auto scalers is the multi-dimensional
pod auto scaler
this new tool combines the horizontal
and vertical pod auto scalers to
intelligently and automatically scale
your workloads both in terms of their
number and their resource requests and
limits
this can help to prevent any potential
for clashes if for example
hpa and vpa were set to scale on the
same metrics
these tools can help you configure your
environment to do a lot of the heavy and
dynamic lifting of optimizing your gk
clusters
but how do you know how optimally your
clusters are running
gke's cost optimization insights feature
provides you with clear information
about how optimally your cluster's
resources are being used right in the
google cloud console
over a selected period of time gk cost
optimization insights can help you
understand the current state of your
clusters by showing you the actual used
requested and allocated resources
for workloads running on your clusters
it shows your actual used and requested
resources as well as the set limits
not only does cost optimization insights
give you convenient visibility into the
efficiency of your clusters and
workloads it can also make suggestions
on how to improve your clusters and
workloads efficiency
in this video you learned about just a
few of the great tools gke has to help
you run your clusters as optimally and
efficiently as possible
gk auto scalers can help reduce the time
and effort needed to keep your clusters
in their most optimal state
gke autopilot mode takes things a step
further by having google maintain your
cluster's worker nodes eliminating the
bin packing problem and allowing you to
focus more on running your applications
the multi-dimensional pod autoscaler
simplifies the task of auto-scaling your
kubernetes workloads directly
and cost optimization insights gives you
a way to see how efficient your clusters
really are at just a glance these are
just a few of the tools available for
you to use to keep your clusters running
optimally be sure to check out the best
practices for cost optimization guide in
the gk documentation for more
with the concepts discussed in this
video we're confident you'll be on your
way to building a gke cluster that suits
your needs
you can get started with gke by visiting
the google cloud console and checking
out the links below
and stay tuned for our next videos where
we dive deeper into gke topics
[Music]